Apple's M3 Max ship just leaked and it's
gonna be better than any of us ever
imagined myself included and trust me I
had some High Hopes And it looks like
apple is going to exceed them Mark
German just leaked a brand new discovery
from a third-party Mac app developer
within test logs destined for the new
high-end 14 and 16-inch MacBook Pros and
the most shocking part from that leak is
the actual core counts with the M3 Max
coming with an unprecedented 16 CPU
cores a huge upgrade from the current 12
core M2 Max with 33 percent more CPU
cores and in a minute I'm gonna give you
guys some performance estimates that are
going to blow your mind with some
calculations that I'm gonna run to
provide you guys with a ton of value but
first I've got to get into the craziest
part of it all I've been digging through
some of Mark German's old chip leaks and
I've just figured out that apple is
actually planning a secret upgrade
exclusively for the M3 Max chip one that
Mac fans have been asking for ever since
the release of Apple silicon I believe
that for the first time ever Apple will
finally be giving the M3 Max more CPU
performance than the M3 Pro with 16 CPU
cores instead of 14 and this is a huge
deal because for both the M1 Max and M2
Max chips the CPU performance has been
literally identical to the M1 Pro and M2
Pro chips and this has obviously been
very annoying to Mac buyers who don't
really care that much about GPU
performance making the max chip useless
to them and the big problem is that some
of those users who need CPU power also
need more RAM but apple is forcing them
to upgrade to the Mac ship with double
the GPU cores just to get that extra Ram
with no benefit at all to the actual CPU
performance but now users who do
programming music production photo
editing and much more will be salivating
over the M3 Max because that chip will
finally get more CPU performance over
the regular M3 Pro now if you don't
believe me let me show you my train of
research and how I figured this out a
couple of months back in May Mark German
leaked the core count of the M3 Pro chip
with a 12 core CPU and an 18 core GPU
which all seemed pretty normal because
we know that the M3 family of chips is
all about tsmc's brand new three
nanometer chip technology that's going
to be much more efficient and have
better performance per watt but then
when I saw the latest M3 Max ship leak
from German showing off a massive 16 CPU
cores my initial impression was that the
previous 12 core M3 Pro chip leak was
simply wrong seeing as there is a huge
four core discrepancy between them but
then I noticed this the M3 Pro chip that
was found in developer log tests had 18
GPU cores which is actually less than
the current unbend M2 Pro which has 19
GPU cores so why would Apple downgrade
from 19 to 18 on the new M3 Pro well
it's because the M3 Pro chip that Mark
German found was actually the bend chip
model destined for the base 14-inch
MacBook Pro because if you look at the
current base model it does also have a
bin chip which means that some of the
cores are disabled with only 10 CPU
cores versus 12 and 16 GPU cores
compared to the full 19 that you get on
the upgraded M2 Pro if you pay more so
this this essentially means that Apple
actually has another unbinned version of
the M3 Pro with likely 20 GPU cores and
likely 14 CPU cores that you can upgrade
to with 10 performance cores and four
efficiency cores but guess what the M3
Max chip has that you can't get on the
M3 Pro an extra two performance cores to
bring it up to 16 CPU course total that
Mark German just leaked which will be
packing a record 12 performance cores
and four efficiency cores so finally the
M3 Max will be getting a CPU performance
upgrade over the M3 Pro which is
something that I thought Apple would do
from the very beginning because it just
makes sense to make the M3 Max better in
terms of both CPU and GPU workloads and
because of that I believe the M3 Max
chips are gonna sell like hot cakes now
becoming much more desirable to
everybody who needs more CPU power and
it's going to be an absolute genius
secret surprise when Apple reveals these
chips sometime next year and by the way
about the release date they're likely
going to come sooner than we all
expected because we just got a report
from the information saying that tsmc's
three nanometer chip yields have greatly
improved from about 55 percent which was
absolutely terrible and that caused the
worries about the delays up to around 70
to 80 percent yield right now which
basically tells us that we should expect
the M3 chip this fall and if we do get
the M3 this fall that means the M3 Pro
and Max should be coming next year
either in the spring or summer at the
latest but now with all that said let's
get into the fun part calculating and
estimating the performance of the
Behemoth 16 core M3 Max chip now what
we're going to base this on is a leaked
M3 chip Benchmark from Tech Reeve on
Twitter showing the geekbench 5 scores
as 2500 for single core and 11
000 for multi-core this basically
represents a 29.2 boost in single core
compared to the M2 Chip which honestly
seems too good to be true because the M2
Chip was only around 11.5 faster than
the M1 in terms of single girl
performance but of course we are
expecting the new three nanometer tip
technology to be a huge upgrade but then
Tech Reeve came out and said that the
three nanometer process isn't going to
be as good as he initially expected so
the 29 boost is probably unrealistic so
because of that let's just settle on a
more plausible 20 boost in terms of
single core performance for the new M3
chip this means that we should end up
with around 2 thousand three hundred and
twenty points in geekbench 5 single core
and from that we can actually measure
the performance of just the efficiency
cores Alone by taking the single core
score and multiplying it by four total
performance cores within the M3 to give
us
9283 points from P cores alone and then
if we take the leaked 11 000 multi-core
score which I think is actually accurate
and minus out the performance core
performance we're left with around a
thousand seven hundred and sixteen point
eight points from the four efficiency
cores or basically
429.2 from each E chord so now let's use
that estimated score information to
calculate the performance of the M3 Max
chip first of all one thing we need to
note is that the M3 Max ships single
core performance is likely going to be a
bit higher than the regular M3 chip
because just by looking at the current
M2 Max its single core performance is
6.88 higher than the M2 Chip so let's be
a bit more conservative and apply a five
percent boost to the single core score
of the M3 Max compared to the M3 giving
us an estimated score of
2436.84 single core performance and now
with that said let's move on to the
multi-core calculations in the past with
the M1 and M2 family it chips I observed
that as you added more performance cores
like with the bend Pro and Max chips
that had six and eight performance cores
there was actually inefficiency loss in
terms of the final multi-core
performance score specifically a 9.5
loss for the binned M1 Pro and a 14 loss
for the M1 Max and seeing as the M3 Max
chip will have 12 performance cores we
can expect an even bigger efficiency
loss so let's just guess around a 20
loss for 12 performance course so now
what I'm going to do is take the single
core score of
2436 and take away 20 to give us a score
of around
1949 per each performance core then we
can multiply that number by a total of
12 performance cores to end up with a
massive 23
393 points from the performance cores
alone and since we know there's going to
be four efficiency cores in the M3 Max
we can add back in the same
1716.8 score from the M3s for efficiency
cores to give us a grand total of 25
110 multi-core score for the M3 Max chip
in geekbench 5. that would essentially
make the new M3 Max almost as fast as
the current M2 Ultra chip which scores
around 28 000 points being only 11.5
percent faster than the estimated
multi-core performance of the M3 Max
which is absolutely insane and comparing
the M3 Max to the previous M2 Max we're
looking at a massive
64.8 percent faster which is crazy but
it makes sense because of the new three
nanometer technology and the extra four
performance course and now Translating
that estimated performance over to
geekbench 6 is quite difficult because
it uses a new more realistic testing
model but here are my own personal
estimates I'm thinking the M3 Max should
score around
3278 points and geekbench sixes single
core and a massive twenty thousand
twenty four points in multi-core what
which is actually right behind the
current M2 Ultra and it's crazy to think
that you're going to get that much
performance in a MacBook Pro chassis
without even having to get the huge Mac
Studio it's just going to be crazy so
with all that said hopefully you'll
enjoy this video and my performance
estimations and if you did go ahead and
comment down below and subscribe right
above and check out one of those two
videos right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
foreign